au stade robert barran l'entamé de match
et plaisir oise après une pénalité
transformée dès la première minute de
jeu le demi de mêlée saint quentinois
jour rapidement ce coup franc à cinq
mètres de la ligne d'en-but marne et le
coup de malice et transformé 10 3 après
six minutes de jeu dans cette première
période les joueurs de philippe behar
sont bien aidé par la maladresse des
visiteurs et surtout par ce mauvais
geste synonyme de carton jaune
en supériorité numérique les bleus et
jaunes récitent leur rugby basé sur une
conquête solide et des lancements de jeu
tout feu tout flamme sur cette déviation
en touche
françois le vilain file sous les poteaux
pour retour des vestiaires changement de
registre les plaisirs wa deviennent
fébrile il recule à l'impact
les espaces se créent c'est tout le
stade robert barran qui se met à douter
il n'en fallait pas plus aux visiteurs
pour inscrire deux essais et revenir à
quatre longueurs à cinq minutes du coup
de sifflet final plaisir ne mène plus
que 20 16 on se dit alors que le prc va
laisser échapper le match jusqu'à ce
maul pénétrant des gros à la dernière
action de jeu
victoire à l'arraché 25-16 les plaisirs
oies se qualifie pour les playoff pour
la deuxième saison consécutive mais non
sans frayeur ça n'est ce pas en france
et moi qui marque mais on sent essai
collectif quand même c'est les gros
c'est une action des nations collectif
qui était assez importante parce que à
la fin du match ça commence à se
resserrer
ça devenait dix ans on a fait une
deuxième mi temps qui n'était pas
d'inquiéter pas du niveau 1 pour une
équipe qui veut se qualifier qui veut
jouer les 32e de finale donc c'est
décevant mais c'est décevant parce
qu'elle est dans le groupe i les joueurs
qu'on pêche ou le jeu aujourd'hui
comparé à leur niveau
donc pour préparer les phases finales
c'est quand même pas bons sur les
derniers matchs contre des équipes qui
ont plus rien à gagner de faire une
prestation défensive aussi faible quoi
je dirai rien